whenever we go away for a month what we
do is provide for the audience future
headlines because people
people need to know what is going to
happen and if we're not here every week
to report what's happening we will tell
you what's going to happen in the next
month here are the future headlines for
july yvaldi texas police department
still waiting in hallway
ivanka published his new book you're
right my dad's an will you buy
my clothes down
[Applause]
uh battered crypto investors flock to
i'll suck your dick corn
[Applause]
uh herschel walker admits to fathering
nick cannon wow that's
outrageous
uh libraries in texas to offer impotent
gun nut story hours
biden falls off stationary bike
uh people people who fled l.a for idaho
during pandemic realized they up
san francisco shoplifters steal security
guards
[Applause]
amber heard now on cameo says crapping
in your bed will cost extra
and
dave chappelle shocker i'm an asian
woman named diane
you